get good
if you want to have success in whatever
field you're getting into then you need
to be good you have to get good you have
to be one of the best people who does
what you do if you want to have success
now this comes as a result of uh one of
my youtube viewers love you guys uh ian
asked the question my big dream is to
one day be a professional speaker i also
have little dreams that i would like to
accomplish if you have any advice or can
help in any way i'm open to correction
opinions advice etc thanks evan this is
a great question and one i can relate to
very well because i make part of my
career as being a professional speaker
if you want to be a professional speaker
you want to have success in this field
then you need to get good you need to
practice i went to your youtube channel
and there's not a single uploaded video
of you talking now maybe this is you
know a different channel that you're
posting from and and you have some
hidden channel that you're practicing
your heart out on but you need to
practice if this is your big goal this
is your big dream this is what you want
to do you have to make it important
right and that comes through practice
look at my channel okay
twice a day new videos are coming up
this means something to me this is one
of the most
exciting and important days of my week
when i sit down and it's video creation
day making my own stuff answering your
questions sharing believe related
knowledge that i want to put out there
to the world and that helps fuel my
speaking career
and if you want to get there you need to
practice
so it took me 800 videos to get to the
point where i could watch one of my own
videos and not be embarrassed 800 videos
and then it took me 1400 videos to get
to the point where i was
motivated by watching my own message it
was kind of an outside the body
experience i was watching my own video
and like wow that's really good i'm
excited by it i'm ready to go destroy
the day this is going to be awesome it
took me 1400 videos you got to practice
you got to get really good now you guys
are lucky you're lucky because you know
for those of you who are new to the wave
who are just joining in you missed all
the pain and all the mediocrity and all
the average videos that came before this
right you missed all the other
1500 videos that came before this one
there are some people like
mark drager
who've been here from the beginning and
who've been fans and commenting and
supporting and stuck through all the
okay stuff that i put out but every
every month every week every day they
get better because i practice and that's
what you need to do you need to practice
and get better
so make a commitment
to every day launching two new videos on
your youtube channel even if you feel
uncomfortable even if it's not your best
stuff don't worry because
if you do that every day
at the end of the year at the end of
next year at the end of the year after
that you're going to become so much
better and you'll have speaking
opportunities come to you i get people
finding me on my youtube channel and
flying me to malaysia and flying me to
florida and flying me to all these
different locations because they see the
videos they see i can speak and they
want to hire me to come speak at their
event
that's how you can build an entire
business but you've got to stop dreaming
get out of your head get out of my one
day i'm going to do this and start
taking action
believe for those of you watching like
the video you can see more just like it
by subscribing to the channel thank you
so much i'll see you soon
every week i share my best information
to help you fuel your business forward
in my newsletter check it out below
hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
riseonline.com and i want to say evan
carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period